más tarde si brice todo el día y les voy
a hablar sería libertad de expresión a
la lírica que es la libertad de
expresión la libertad de expresión de
una de estas cosas que todo escuchamos
pero no estamos precisamente seguros de
lo que significa es aquí dónde podría
hablarles 20 minutos sobre libros
autores y los momentos mientras busco
palabras largas y olvidado intentando
parecer un intelectual pero como sé que
no hay nada que les pueda decir que no
haya sido mejor dicho que un caballero
otra época les presentaré dos citas que
rápidamente capturan qué es la libertad
de expresión
bueno bueno para uruguay la libertad de
expresión es poder decir lo que la gente
no quiere oír después de hablar de lo
que queramos aun cuando haya gente que
nos quiere acallar al mismo tiempo se
dice que voltear dijo no comparto lo que
dices pero defenderé hasta la muerte tu
derecho a decirlo en política después de
hablar sobre cualquier tema sin ponernos
a pelear yo pero dividir la opinión del
otro en la cotidianidad de fuera hablar
de reír sobre cualquier cosa sin temor a
perder el trabajo o terminar en la
cárcel en definitiva la libertad de
expresión después de silvio giramos con
la responsable condición de que nos
hagamos responsables de lo que decimos
ya bueno es súper básico es súper normal
es muy sencillo tiempo debía dejarse por
algo tan básico y tan esencial para la
democracia para explicarle eso les voy a
contar la historia de un perrito no sé
de conocerlos pero según dos perros
pequeños gorditos y súper tiernos
bueno lo que pasa es que para freud el
humor era muy importante pues que una
mentada nuestra intimidad suele ser el
humorista el que dice lo que todos
pensamos pero que nadie se atrevería a
decir en público tengan esté presente
mientras le cuenta la historia las cosas
que vemos es que había un joven escocés
que estaba bregando y su volver a
encontraba aquí es su perrito porque era
lo más tierno que hay hablaba todo el
día el perro le mandaba por instagram
isna bachata a todo el mundo fotos de
ese perro y como que contaría un juego
el final fría no importa y le contaba a
todo el mundo sobre su querido entonces
paul yo sólo por molestarlo se le
ocurrió enseñarle al perrito a levantar
la patita como un nazi solo por molestar
y sólo brincar no va
ahí está el vídeo es muy importante que
lo vean porque el fondo es un meme y en
la mitad de la presentación
tiene que el juego le gusta ver un vídeo
de como si fuese un perro nazi de verdad
y ahí está es el truco
es una estupidez verdad y luego
obviamente este tipo subió el video a
internet porque le enseñó a levantar la
patita al perro que un pie y lo hizo
salvar malestar se hizo viral porque a
mucha gente le pareció muy chistoso lo
absurdo de ver un perrito así gordito y
viendo un vídeo de youtube entonces se
hizo muy viral y fue un gran bebé ya
bien después de dos semanas el tipo que
subió este vídeo sólo vamos a estar la
mayoría
se fue detenido tubería y estuvo en un
juicio por dos años porque según el
fiscal lo que estaba tratando de hacer
era difundir el odio y el antisemitismo
a través de ese perrito lo que tiene
porque hay una parte y deporte pero
asuntos de tiempo pero al principio y sé
que eso lo hace esta cuestión para
molestar a la bola y que logran formar
en lo peor que se le podía ocurrir en un
nazi entonces no es como que lo está
apoyando sino que es todo lo contrario
está tratando de dejar como lo peor del
mundo la cuestión es qué
el segundo el fiscal la idea era que
este perro era un perro políticamente
extremista y que estaba tratando de
atraer o reclutar más personas que
estuviese de la misma línea
y esta persona no puedo encontrar
trabajo ni nada porque frente a la ley
era un extremista un totalitario y todas
estas cosas que en verdad eran bastante
infundada pero bueno
bueno la cuestión es qué
el enigma es que este tipo de tratar de
transformar a un perrito en un nazi solo
para molestarlo porque pensaba que era
lo peor que había en empezar a dar
sentencia a juzgar como si realmente
fuese así como si realmente los apoyara
países tenemos que pensar un poco para
poder entender la estupidez de esta
cuestión tenemos que pensar en por qué
hoy llamado los nazis lo digamos
precisamente porque conocimos sus
atrocidades porque hablamos vimos
películas y les hablamos lo con nuestro
padre esta cuestión y escuchamos en
clases de historia lo terrible que fue
el holocausto el rechazo que sentimos
por estas personas y por esa ideología
asesina es a través del diálogo que
hubiese pasado si en lugar de conversar
y comentar los crímenes contra la
humanidad lo que hubiésemos hecho sería
contarlo nunca hablar de iu o prohibirlo
y ponerlo bajo la alfombra lo más
probable es que la prohibición no
hubiese traído atención de las personas
o se hubiese salido a la luz como algo
neutro quizás o probablemente hubiese
sido tergiversado para causar simpatía
lo que es terrible lo que pasa es que la
libertad de expresión o sea la
prohibición en lugar de haber suprimido
esta ideología la habría beneficiado
ya es esta la importancia de la libertad
de expresión no sólo nos sirve construir
nuestro futuro como vimos al principio
sino que además nos permiten no volver a
cometer los errores del pasado
y ahí es cuando la distancia con el
señor polémica últimamente se inventó
voy a introducir toda idea últimamente
se inventó esta cuestión de el discurso
de odio que es una idea que te permite
como atropellar o callar a la fuerza
otras ideas y también se puso de moda
protestar no lo que hizo una persona o
lo que piensa una persona sino pero
influir que tenga un espacio para hablar
una sala en una universidad
independiente la ideología toda esta
cuestión obviamente y es que tengo una
espacio para hablar que está acá por
ejemplo o que le preste una sala en
donde universidad estuvimos en eeuu esa
cuestión de un psiquiatra que más y más
tiene libros de autoayuda que lo
trataban de tratar como como
facilitadores porque los gringos están
locos tuvimos el caso del candidato se
expandió a otros y voy a notar que
terminando una golpiza y abajo tuvimos
una figura pública que también estuve
llamando como deber a golpear a ciertas
personas y que era necesario bueno esa
es una cara de la moneda es supernatural
que una parte de un grupo político que
está en un extremo o trate de callar a
la fuerza el otro extremo del partido de
otro del espectro político y es súper
normal que este extremo también trate de
callar a los que están acá una bestia
que sea el visceral no racional
y una intelectual pero se da pero
tenemos que pensar que cuando hablamos
de odio en el pasado fue definido esta
cuestión de odio por otras personas por
el otro grupo político tuvimos cosas
como la ley de defensa permanente la
democracia creo prohibió el partido
comunista y entre esos exilio a pablo
neruda nuestro nobel entonces tenemos
que pensar que quizás ayer fue pablo
neruda hoy día quizás sea cast precisa
mañana se tuvo la libertad de expresión
tiene ser un marco común en que todas
las personas de izquierda derecho puedan
conversar y dialogar pueden discrepar
pero de seguida se tienen que responder
con ideas y no con golpes
bueno este poema es muy conocido lo más
probable es que la mayoría de ustedes ya
lo hayan leído pero me gustaría bien
sabe el poder de denuncia que puede
tener
en la libertad de expresión para luchar
contra una tiranía
primero vinieron por los comunistas y me
dije nada porque no era comunista y
luego vinieron por los judíos y no dije
nada porque ya no era judío
luego dinero por los sindicalistas y no
dije nada porque no era sindicalista
luego vinieron por los católicos y no
dije nada porque era protestante y luego
vinieron por mí y entonces ya no había
nadie que dijera nada
la libertad de expresión en estas cosas
que no nos pueden arrebatar reír crítica
y debatir de las cosas más importantes
que tenemos y siempre nos tenemos que
poner algún político
cuando la restrinja como dijo thomas
jefferson la llama de la libertad
bueno la del precio de la libertad es
eterna custodia y ahora los invito a
custodiar está abierta y no dejar que
sus llamas apague muchas gracias
[Música]
y